معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
اتوجه بالتحيه والتقدير لاخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه
الله ولكم اخي صاحب السمور الملكي ولي
العهد على استضافه هذه القمه العربيه
التي نثق بانها ستنجح في مواجهه التحديات
الاقليميه والعالميه
التي تواجه امتنا
وتحويلها لفرص تعزز الامن والاستقرار
والسلام في منطقتنا وتحقق طموحات وامال
شعوب امتنا العربيه وفي هذه المناسبه
فاننا نشيد بما حققته المملكه من انجازات
تحت قيادتكم على جميع المستويات على طريق
الرفعه
والنمائي والازدهار كما اتوجه بالش
العرفان لاخي فخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد
تبون رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه الشعبيه
الديمقراطيه على رئاسته الناجحه للقمه
السابقه
واوجهه بهذه المناسبه تحيه اكبر وتقدير
لاشقائنا قاده الدول العربيه
وشعوبها على مواقبهم الثابته تجاه شعبنا
وقضيتنا العادله كما
ونرحب بزياده الرئيس بشار الاسد رئيس
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه اخا عزيزا بين
اهله واخوانه الاخ الرئيس
في قرار اممي تاريخيا غير مسبوق احيد
الامم المتحده في مقرها بنيويورك منذ ايام
الذكرى 75 للنكبه نكبه الشعب الفلسطيني
التي لا زالت تتوالى احداثها واثارها
الماساويه منذ العام
1948 حتى يومنا هذا والتي ارتكبت العصابات
الصهيونيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلالها اكثر من 51 مجزره موثقه لدينا
ودمرت اكثر من 530 قريه
فلسطينيه
موثقه لدينا
ان هذا القرار الاممي التاريخي الهام يشكل
نحضا للروايه الصهيونيه الاسرائيليه التي
تنكرت في النكبه ولفقت الروايات المزيفه
حول علاقات الشعب الفلسطيني بارض وطنه
والجرائم التي ارتكبت بحقهم
اننا ايها السيدات والساده نؤكد رفض ذلك
الاستمرار استباحه سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لارضنا ومقدساتنا ونطالب
المجتمع الدولي بمحاسبه اسرائيل على
جرائمها بحق شعبنا وانتهاكاتها للقانون
الدولي
وتوفير الحمايه الدوليه له ونحن من جانبنا
سنواصل مسيرتنا النضاليه
لمواجهه القهر والعدوان الاسرائيلي كما
سنواصل
جهودناشيه والقانونيه في المحافل والمحاكم
كافه لاستعاده حقوق شعبنا وفي المقدمه
منها المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ومحكمه
العدل الدوليه اضافه الى استمرار السعي
للحصول على العضويه الكامله في الامم
المتحده وهنا
منكم جميعا الوقوف الى جانبنا لدعم تنفيذ
قرار الجمعيه العامه الاخير وتقديم
المرافعه
المكتوبه من قبل دوركم امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه على امل ان تصدر هذه المحكمه
رايها الاستشاري وفتواها حول قانونيه وشكل
واهليه النظام الذي اقامته اسرائيل دوله
الاحتلال والابرتين على ارض فلسطين وفي
هذا الصدد نؤكد استعدادنا للعمل مع هذه
القمه العربيه
بقياده المملكه العربيه السعوديه من اجل
انجاح الجهود العربيه والاقليميه والدوليه
في اطار من الشراكه والتعارون وايجاد حلول
لازمات المنطقه وصولا لتحقيق الامن
والسلام والازدهار لشعوبنا
في كل واحد منكم في الوطن وفي الشتات
ونعتذر ونعتز بمسيرتنا النضاليه وسوف
نواصل العمل من اجل وحده شعبنا وارضنا
وتحقيق المصالحه الوطنيه على اساس
الالتزام بمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
والشرعيه الدوليه والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته